la desigualdad mundial frente a la
emergencia de salud pública global
mientras los países ricos se aseguran
las dosis suficientes de las vacunas
contra el cob y 19 los más pobres
continúan con las manos vacías un
desigual reparto que este año ha
centrado las conversaciones en el foro
virtual de davos con mandatarios como el
sudafricano reclamando una justa
distribución del antídoto contra el
virus
los países ricos del mundo salieron y
adquirieron grandes dosis de vacunas de
los desarrolladores y fabricantes de
estas vacunas y algunos países incluso
han ido más allá y han adquirido hasta
cuatro veces más de lo que necesita su
población con el objetivo de acaparar
las vacunas porque los innings
en orden y ahora se está haciendo con la
exclusión de otros países que más las
necesitan
desde hace semanas la organización
mundial de la salud viene señalando la
necesidad de que la vacuna llegue a todo
el mundo no como una cuestión de caridad
sino como un beneficio global a largo
plazo y para ello la oms se puso en
marcha el plan internacional kóvacs con
la que busca hacer llegar la inyección a
más de 180 países pobres y de renta
media su llamado al que se unió la
canciller alemana afirmando que una
distribución equitativa es la única vía
para superar la pandemia me queda aún
más claro que antes que tenemos que
optar por un enfoque multilateral que un
enfoque de autoaislamiento no resolverá
nuestros problemas lo vemos en primer
lugar en la cuestión de la vacunación ya
que es la vía de salida de la pandemia y
aquí por supuesto vemos la relación
entre las palabras y las acciones
el nacionalismo de las vacunas podría
generar un fuerte impacto en la economía
mundial
las billonarias en la cámara de comercio
internacional pero sobre todo mientras
la mayoría de la población mundial no
logre vacunarse seguirán en juego
millones de vidas cuando el mundo supera
los 100 millones de contagios